Qu'est-ce qu'elle fait ?
Elle appelle les premiers secours.
Il y a deux voies principales de réparation.
La première prend l'ADN et rassemble les deux morceaux.
Ce système n'est pas très efficace
car, parfois, une base se décroche
ou bien une base est ajoutée.
C'est un système qui fonctionne pour éliminer un gène
mais ce n'est pas ainsi que nous voulons modifier le génome.
La second voie de réparation est beaucoup plus intéressante.
Dans cette voie de réparation,
il faut un morceau d'ADN homologue.
Dans un organisme diploïde comme l'être humain,
nous recevons une copie de notre génome de notre mère et une de notre père,
si une est endommagée,
on peut utiliser l'autre chromosome pour la réparer.
Voici l'explication.
La réparation est faite
et le génome est à nouveau sûr.
Nous pouvons détourner cela
en fournissant un mauvais morceau d'ADN,
un morceau homologue aux extrémités
mais différent au milieu.
Vous pouvez mettre ce que vous voulez au milieu
et la cellule se fera duper.
Vous pouvez changer une lettre,
enlever des lettres
et, surtout, y insérer du nouvel ADN,
comme un cheval de Troie.
CRISPR sera extraordinaire
en ce qui concerne le nombre d'avancées scientifiques différentes
qu'il va catalyser.
Ce qu'il a de spécial est la modularité du système cible.
Nous insérons de l'ADN dans des organismes depuis des années.
Du fait de la modularité du système cible,
il est possible d'insérer l'ADN à un endroit précis.
Le fait est qu'il y a beaucoup débat concernant le fait que ce soit peu cher
et facile.
Je gère un laboratoire communautaire.
Je commence à recevoir des mails de personnes disant :
« Hey, je viens aux portes ouvertes,
peut-être pourrais-je utiliser CRISPR pour modifier mon génome ? »
(Rires)
Sérieusement.
Je leur dis : « Non, vous ne pouvez pas ».
(Rires)
« Mais on m'a dit que c'était peu cher et facile. »
Nous allons parler un peu de cela.
A quel point est-ce peu cher ?
C'est peu cher en comparaison.
Cela fera passer le prix du matériel pour une expérience moyenne
de milliers de dollars à des centaines de dollars
et cela fait aussi gagner du temps.
A la place de semaines, il faut des jours.
C'est génial.
Il faut travailler dans un labo professionnel ;
vous ne ferez rien de significatif en dehors d'un labo professionnel.
N'écoutez pas ceux qui disent
que cela est faisable dans votre cuisine.
Ce genre de travail n'est pas facile.
Sans oublier qu'il y a une guerre des brevets,
même si vous inventez quelque chose,
l'institut Broad et UC Berkeley mènent une incroyable guerre des brevets.
Cela est très fascinant à voir
car ils s'accusent mutuellement de revendications frauduleuses
et ils ont des gens qui disent :
« J'ai signé mes notes ici ou là. »
Cela ne sera pas réglé avant des années.
Et quand cela le sera,
vous pouvez parier que vous paierez un droit de licence important
pour pouvoir utiliser cela.
Est-ce vraiment peu cher ?
Cela est peu cher si vous faites de la recherche basique et avez un labo.
Qu'en est-il de la facilité ? Parlons-en.
Le diable est toujours dans les détails.
Nous n'en savons pas tant que ça sur les cellules.
Ce sont encore des boites noires.
Par exemple, nous ignorons pourquoi certains ARN guidés fonctionnent très bien
et certains ne fonctionnent pas.
Nous ignorons pourquoi certains cellules veulent se réparer d'une façon
et certaines préfèrent l'autre façon.
En plus de cela,
il y a le problème de l'insertion du système dans la cellule
pour commencer.
Dans une boite de Petri, c'est assez facile
mais si vous voulez le faire sur un organisme complet,
cela devient complexe.
Cela est faisable avec le sang ou la moelle osseuse --
ce sont les cibles de nombreuses recherches.
Il y a une super histoire d'une petite fille
qui a été sauvée de la leucémie
en extrayant son sang, l'éditant puis en le réinjectant
avec un précurseur de CRISPR.
C'est un axe de recherche sur lequel les gens vont travailler.
Actuellement, si vous le voulez dans tout le corps,
vous devrez probablement utiliser un virus.
Vous prenez le virus, y insérez CRISPR,
laissez le virus infecter la cellule.
Mais vous avez inséré le virus
et nous ignorons les effets à long terme.
CRISPR a également des effets secondaires,
un très faible pourcentage, mais cela existe bien.
Que se passera-t-il au fil du temps ?
Ce ne sont pas des questions triviales,
des scientifiques essaient de les résoudre
et elles seront, on l'espère, résolues un jour.
Mais ce n'est pas immédiat, cela est loin d'être gagné.
Alors, est-ce vraiment simple ?
Si vous passez quelques années à travailler sur un système précis,
oui.
L'autre problème
est que nous ne savons pas vraiment comment réaliser une chose spécifique
en changeant des points précis du génome.
Nous sommes loin de comprendre
comment, par exemple, donner des ailes aux cochons.
Ou même rajouter une patte -- cela m'irait bien.
Cela serait plutôt cool.
Mais ce qu'il se passe,
c'est que CRISPR est utilisé par des milliers de scientifiques
pour réaliser des travaux très importants
comme la création de meilleurs modèles de maladies chez les animaux
ou des façons de produire des produits chimiques utiles,
de manière industrielle,
ou même faire des recherches simples sur ce que font les gènes.
C'est l'histoire de CRISPR que nous devrions raconter
et je n'aime pas les aspects plus tape-à-l’œil
qui noient tout cela.
Beaucoup de scientifiques ont travaillé à la réalisation de CRISPR
et ce qui est intéressant
est le soutien de la société envers ces scientifiques.
Pensez-y.
Nous avons une infrastructure permettant à un certain pourcentage de personnes
de passer leur temps à faire de la recherche.
Cela fait de nous tous les inventeurs de CRISPR
et je dirais que cela fait de nous tous des bergers de CRISPR.
Nous avons tous des responsabilités.
Je vous conseille de vraiment vous informer sur ce genre de technologies
car seulement ainsi
pourrons-nous guider le développement de ces technologies,
l'utilisation de ces technologies
et nous assurer, finalement, que le résultat est positif --
pour la planète et pour nous.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)